I'm Dr sonal I have I'm PhD in computer
science and I'm presently working as
assistant professor in Bennett
University in India and I'm also founder
of children who clothed with a motive to
technically train every child and make
them competent a job really so we are
planned we are working on various
innovative ways to make coding and
computer science and technology
interesting and accessible to them so
today start is on responsible AI
uh we will be talking about like what is
responsible AI why do we need it how it
has been implemented in the top forms
and what its future
so a few years back Microsoft released
its uh maybe in the 2016 Microsoft
released its AI based chat bot uh Tay
via Twitter so the bot was trained to
generate its responses based on the
interactions with the users but there
was a catch various users started
posting offensive tweets towards the
board resulting in team making replies
in the same language the bot basically
turned into a racist sexist and Hate
Machine so less than a day after the
initial release it was uh taken offline
by the developer company followed by an
official apology for the Bots
controversial tweets so this is just one
of the examples of the dark side of AI
one of the many to be honest so the
world knows quite a few cases where the
AI went wrong
so for some the term AI can provoke
thoughts of progressive and productivity
for uh others the output is less
positive so many concerns such as unfair
decisions what has been replaced and
lack of privacy and security are valid
so to make things worse many of these
issues are unique to AI this means
existing guidelines and laws are not
suitable to address them this is where
responsible AI comes in it aims to
address the issues and create
accountability for AI systems so the
development of fair trustworthy AI is up
to the description of the data scientist
and the team of uh scientists and
software developers who write and deploy
a specific organizations uh AI
algorithmic models
this means that the steps required to
prevent discrimination and ensure
transparency vary from company to
company
so what is responsible AI it's basically
a set of principles or guidelines we can
say and normative declarations which
used to document and regulate how
artificial intelligence system should be
developed deployed and governed to
comply with ethics and laws so
organizations attempting to deploy AI
models responsibly first build a
framework with predefined principles
ethics and rules to govern the AI
so the framework can include details on
what data can be collected how model
should be evaluated and how to best
deploy and monitor the models so
framework and also Define who is
accountable for any negative outcomes of
AI
so Frameworks will differ between
companies some will define specific
approaches and others will be more open
to interpretation so they all seek to
achieve the same thing this is to create
AI systems that are interpretable fair
safe respectable for a user's privacy
why responsible AI is important
as AI advances more and more companies
use various machine learning models to
automate and improve the task that used
to require human intervention and when
we talked about like ml model an ml
model is an algorithm like we use
variety of algorithms like decision
trees random forest or neural networks
what is more ml model they are trained
on data to generate the prediction and
help a computer system or a human or
their tend them to make decisions
decisions can include anything from
telling whether the transaction is fraud
to accept decline loan applications to
detect brain tumors on MRIs or working
as a diagnosis support tool for doctors
so the models and data they are trained
on are far from perfect they may
introduce intended and unintended
negative outcomes not only the positive
ones as we talked about the day that we
are already talking about so by taking
the responsible approach
companies will be able to create AI
systems that are efficient and
compatible with regulations ensure that
development process consider all the
ethical detail and societal implications
of AI track and mitigate buyers in the
AI models build trust in AI prevent or
minimize the negative effects and get
rid of ambiguity about
whose default it is if something in AI
goes wrong
so all of this with uh will help
organizations pursuing AI uh Power
prevent potential reputational and
financial damage down the road so
responsible AI isn't something that
exists in the theory three major Tech
Giants Google Microsoft IBM and many
other uh technical organizations they
have called for artificial intelligence
to be regulated and build their own
governance Frameworks and guidelines
so this brings us to the heart and soul
of responsible artificial intelligence
that is what are the key principles of a
responsible AI
so the
this picture here represents a core
principles but their number can vary
from one organization to another not to
mention that the ways that are
interpreted and operationalized can vary
to like first let's talk about fairness
fairness
the principal says that AI systems
should treat everyone fairly and avoid
affecting similarity situated groups of
people in different ways simply put they
should be unbiased
so humans are prone to be biased in
their judgments computer systems in
theory have the potential to be fairer
when making decisions but we should not
forget that ml models learn from Real
World data that is for from our humans
themselves which is highly likely to
contain prices this can lead to unfair
results as initially equal groups of
people may be systematically
disadvantaged because of their gender
race or sexual orientation
so for example Facebook's in a case
study uh it was written that Facebook's
ad serving algorithm was accused of
being discriminatory as it reproduced a
real world gender disparities when
showing job listings even I'm an equally
qualified candidates
proves the necessity to work towards
development systems that are fair and
inclusive for all without favoring
anyone or discriminated against them and
without causing
without causing her so to enable
algorithm fairness you can research
biases and their Clauses in data
uh training data like an unequal
representation of classes in training
data like when the recruitment tool is
shown more resumes from men making women
a minority class identify and document
what impact the technology may have and
how it may behave Define your model
fairness for different use cases update
training and testing data based on the
feedback from those who have who use the
model and how they do it
so quotients to be answered to ensure
fairness
of art like is your AI fair is there any
bias in the training data because that's
the main important concern uh when we
are training the models are those
responsible for developing AI systems
fair-minded
the second uh principle is the
reliability and secure safety
okay first let me cover the previously
insecurity so privacy principle like the
principle of privacy and security says
that AI system should be able to protect
private information and resist attacks
just like other technology so AI systems
are required to comply with privacy laws
and Regulatory bodies that govern the
data collection processes and storage
and ensure the protection of personal
information
so uh in few countries data privacy
cancers like in Europe the data privacy
cancers are addressed by the general
data protection regulation so to ensure
previously and Security in AI we should
develop a data management strategy to
collect and handle data responsibly
Implement a cross-controlled mechanisms
use on-device training when appropriate
Advocate the privacy of ml models so
when we are ensuring the data privacy
and security the question to be answered
is is AI technology violating any
anyone's privacy how do you protect data
against attacks and confirm the security
of your AI
and how will your AI system protect and
manage privacy so as said ml models
learn from the training data to make
predictions on new data inputs so in
many cases especially in the healthcare
industry training data can be quite
sensitive for example the CT scans and
MRIs they contain details that identify
a patient and are known as protected
health information
so when using patient data for AI
purposes companies must do additional
um data preprocessing both such as an
organization and de-identification not
to violate the rules the health
insurance portability and the
accountability rules that acts the
previous year of health records in U.S
and other countries
the next principle talks about the
reliability and safety that is AI system
should operate reliably safely and
consistently under normal circumstances
and in unexpected conditions
organizations must develop AI systems
that provide a robust performance and
are safe to use while minimizing the
negative impact what will happen if
something goes wrong in the AI system
how will the algorithm behave in the
unforeseen scenario AI can be called
reliable if it deals with what if and
adequately responds to the new situation
without doing harm to the users
so to ensure the reliability and safety
of AI
one may want to consider the scenarios
that are more likely to happen and ways
a system May respond to them figure out
how a person can make timely adjustment
to the system if anything goes wrong and
put human Safety First
so when we are working with uh privacy
and safe
uh reliably as I'm sorry reliability and
safety so the quotients which need to be
answered is is your AI system reliable
and stable does it meet performance
requirements and behave as intended and
uh can you govern and monitor the
powerful AI technology
then comes another principles that is
transparency interpretability and
explainability so people should be able
to understand how AI systems are making
the decisions especially when those
decisions impact people's lives so AI is
often a black box rather than a
transparent system meaning it's not that
easy to explain how things work inside
after all while people sometimes uh
can't provide satisfactory explanations
for their own decisions understanding
complex AI systems such as neural
networks can be difficult even for the
machine learning experts so for example
uh in 2019 Apple launched its credit
cards uh people to reply for the card
online and were automatically provided
with credit limits however it turned out
that women were given much lower credit
limits than men in addition to being
unfair it wasn't quite clear how the El
droiter performed and provided the
outputs we can assume that the company
failed with transparency and
explainability principles When
developing this model so all of this
raises many portions in terms of
interpretability and transparency of ml
models so they range from legal concerns
about how our data is being processed to
ethical and moral dilemmas such as the
trolley problem whether a self-driving
car should sacrifice one person to save
the lives of many
so why uh you may have your own vision
of how to make AI transparent and
explainable hey are there some practices
to null over decide on the
interpretability criteria and add them
to a checklist that is which
explanations are required and how will
they be presented made clear what kind
of data AI systems use for word purpose
and what factors affect the final result
document the system's Behavior at
different stages of development and
testing
uh communicate explanations on how a
model Works to end users convey how to
correct the system's mistakes
so questions to be answered to ensure
transparency and integrity is that can
you and your team explain both the
overall decision making process and the
individual predictions generated by your
AI
the next
uh
okay one more uh principle that is
accountability which I have not
mentioned in the slides it says that
people must maintain responsibility for
and meaningful control over the AI
systems
I'm talking about the accountability so
this last but not the least all
stakeholders involved in the development
of AI systems are in charge of the
ethical implementations of their use and
misuse so it is important to clearly
identify the roles and responsibilities
of those who will hold accountability
for the organization's compliance with
the established AI principles so there's
a correlation between the degree of
complexity complexity and autonomy of
the AI system and the responsibility
intensity so the more autonomous AI is
the higher the degree of accountability
of the authorization that develops
deploys or uses the AI systems that's
because the outcomes may be critical in
terms of people's lives and safety
so
working on this principle we need to
answer do you have robust governance
models for your AI system have you
clearly defined the roles and
responsibilities of individual
accountable for AI development
so these are some general principles and
all the organizations they are
developing their own guidelines based on
these principles
now terms like how like implementing the
responsible AI
so
why organizations may take different
routes to create and Implement
responsible AI guidelines there are few
General approaches that can help but put
principles into practice Define what
responsible AI means for your company
make sure the entire organizations is on
the same page in regard to your
responsible AI initiatives for this you
may want to involve top managers and
Executives from different departments to
collaborate on drafting the principles
that will lead uh the design and use of
AI products
uh developing developing principles and
training that is build values that guide
your responsible AI Solutions and
distribute them across the organizations
you may also need to train our different
teams on a company specific approach to
enable responsibility in an AI product
establish human and AI governance
establish the roles and responsibilities
mechanisms for AI performance review and
accountability for the outcomes
then integrate the available tools
evolve your standard machine learning
pipelines including data collection
model built into the left which
responsible AI principles will be met
for this you may offer available methods
and tools provided by industry leaders
like Microsoft Google IBM essential PWC
they offer their responsible AI toolkit
a suit of services covering Frameworks
and leading practices assessments and
Technologies
uh
Google and Microsoft also provides tools
and Frameworks that come under the
umbrella name explainable Ai and
responsible AI resources completely
so it can be difficult to demonstrate
whether an algorithmic model is
performing well for a responsive ability
standpoint so organizations have many
ways can Implement responsible Ai and
demonstrate that they have eliminated
the blood blackpot's AI models so this
current strategies include ensure data
is explainable in a way that a human can
interpret ensure design and decision
making process are documented to the
point where if the mistake occurs it can
be reverse engineered to determine what
what went wrong build a diverse word
culture and promote a constructive
discussions to help mitigate the biases
use interpretable latent features to
help create human understandable data
and create a redress development
processes that value visibility into
each applicant's latent features
so some successful real life examples of
responsible air like the world has
already faced many consequences of AI
failures and in the past few years uh
many organizations have started building
their own governance policies people
like luckily people have this thing
called the brain so they are capable of
learning from mistakes so with the shift
towards the responsible use of AI many
companies have succeeded
many companies they have succeeded with
their projects with time so let's take a
look at few of the real world examples
that IBM helps
yeah so IBM has its own ethics board
dedicated to the issues surrounding
artificial intelligence IBM AI ethics
board is a central body that supports
the creation of ethical and responsible
AI throughout IBM so their guidelines
and resources photos
IBM photos is on include AI trust and
transparency everyday ethics for AI uh
open source Community Resources and
Research into trusted AI so a large
U.S cooperation has teamed up with IBM
to automate its hiring process by
keeping its AI unbiased so in terms of
attracting and recruiting new candidates
it was crucial for the employer to drag
diversity and inclusion while ensuring
fair and trustworthy decisions of its ml
models so the company wanted not only to
put fairness in place by spinning up the
identification of any buyers in hiring
but also to understand how AI models
make decisions so for that they made use
of IBM Watson studio and AI monitoring
and management tool on the cloud pack
for data
then
um State form an insurance company it
develops its responsible AI framework
it's a large group of mutual insurance
companies throughout the United States
they had they have Incorporated AI into
its claim handling process along with
responsible AI strategy the company has
established a governance system that
assigns accountability for AI and allows
for making faster and more informed
decisions while creating even better
customer and employee experiences so the
company's AI model called Dynamic
vehicle assessment model dbam they help
predict the total loss with a high level
of confidence while enabling
transparency regarding the method of
processing insurance claims
hnm they set up responsible AI team and
create their own practical checklist so
it's one of the world's biggest fashion
retailers they use AI capabilities for
their sustainability and supply chain
optimization goals
as well as personalized customer
experience so in 2018 uh the company
created a responsible AI team and
established a practical checklist that
aimed to identify and mitigate potential
harms of AI use
so from then on all hm groups AI
products are designed in accordance with
the nine guiding principles as being
photos beneficial Fair transparent uh
collaborative governed reliable secure
and respectful of privacy so every AI
initiative of the retail giant goes
through many stages of assessment with
uh product teams performing responsible
AI checklist reviews
okay
so some responsible AI Frameworks these
are just two giant examples but they are
many others available these days in the
market so Microsoft has created its own
responsible AI governance framework with
the help from their AI ethics and
effects in engineering and research
committee and office of responsible AI
groups so these groups work together
with Microsoft to spread and unfold
their defined responsible AI values so
uh you can check their websites all the
guidelines toolkit assessment sheets of
both in the case of Microsoft and Google
are available there which can be used by
the other organizations as well there
like the other guidelines created by
them for the AI products being developed
by their team but it can be used and
referred to
while designing your own right lines so
it's responsible for setting the
company-wide rules for responsible AI
through the implementation of governance
and public policy so Microsoft has
implemented a number of responsible AI
guidelines checklist and templates so
all of them are available on their
website so some of these include human
AI interaction guidelines conversational
AI guidelines uh inclusive design
guidelines AI fairness checklist
templates for data sheets AI security
engineering guidance
Google is also they have also have their
own uh set of principles for uh
they also have their responsible AI
practices and they have General
recommended practices for AI like
fairness interpretability privacy
security
Etc
So currently they uh they are also
developing no like they there is a tool
known as know your data which help
developers understand the data sets with
the role of improving data quality so
helping to mitigate fairness and bias
issues so prior teams use these tools to
evaluate they have their entire review
process so they have General assessment
sheets and checklist available on the
website so for any AI product being
developed it goes through the review
process to evaluate their words
alignment with the AI principles
so what's the future of responsible AI
there was
a movie I Robot so the in there the
fictional robot was based on the ideas
of ESAT as more and namely the first law
of Robotics stated that a machine should
not harm a human or by inaction allows a
human to come to harm so in this
situation when the robot could have
saved the life of only one person it
calculated that the chances of saving
Will Smith's character was higher than
the chances of saving his child so this
is typically more dilemma even humans
would find difficult to solve so should
a robot prioritize a child's life should
it save the person who can help Society
more so chat machines make accurate bias
away decisions at all so these are other
questions were about in the field of AI
in these days so as of now when it comes
to Building Technology and using data
responsibly
and ethically organizations are at
different stages of the journey so
responsible AI
is and will continue to be an active
area of research and development with
the aim of creating standard guidelines
for organized uh for organizations
operating in different Industries
so
so we
whatever systems we are working on or
whatever organizations it is our
responsibility to avoid the dark side
and the black boxes of AI so we need to
form our own guidelines governance
policies make sure that the AI uh
whatever AI systems we are creating they
are beneficial to the society instead of
breaking the Harms so that's all from my
side in case of any queries uh I'm open
thank you